do you see anything wrong with what your  son did  so the q shaman's mom was apparently  defending him on 60 minutes and it's a  train wreck let's watch  what what do you mean by wrong what like  wrong  well by wrong it means illegal do you  see the gravity  of it i feel the gravity of it because  my son  is in you know he's he's where he is  right now  he's in jail waiting to be prosecuted  for all the crimes that he committed  that's where he is  if he could take it back he would  because it was illegal  he he walked through open doors he  walked through open doors that he wasn't  allowed to walk through  my son was there but he wasn't a part of  the bad part of it  right that's not a thing that is not a  legally defensible thing  i don't think it's right that it uh  was won fraudulently  yeah well that has nothing to do with  whether your son committed  multiple felonies spoiler alert he did  so subscribe or i'll see you in court